we are currently visiting the first
vertical Farm using aeroponic Towers in
Italy located in the province of Bergamo
in the Lombardi region this aeroponic
Farm was set up by our partners known as
easy peasy where they have 50 aeroponic
Towers in a greenhouse with a total
planting capacity of 3 800 plants
besides the fact that they can save more
than 95 water usage compared to
Conventional farming they use their
freshly harvested aeroponic crops to
provide a true Farm to Table experience
within their farmstay known as
casaclelia this is truly the embodiment
of sustainable farming in Europe where
they are setting the example of
eco-friendly agricultural Solutions in
Italy